pour cet épisode nous sommes à
l'intérieur de la prison de fresnes et
les équipes qui participent aux épreuves
sont celles des surveillants de prison
celle des personnes détenues et
l'indienne koltès à travers plusieurs
épreuves les trois équipes s'affrontent
afin de collecter des fonds pour des
associations quiz parcours du combattant
tir à la corde ou encore quartier des
extraits très relayée sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont suscité l'indignation
d'élus de police mais aussi de
surveillants de prison y compris à fred
weill malama tu vas devoir porter toi
ses lunettes parce que tu vas devoir
traverser et le pièce qui est occupé par
des rayons laser et l'électrique ce qui
veut dire qu'à chaque fois que tu va les
toucher tu recevras une petite décharge
électrique j'ai pas signé pour ça je
n'ai rien signé en fait certains la [ __ ]
et dépasse le cadre de la récession avec
le karting dans un état blanc pendant sa
semaine première je pense pas que ça
contribue à la personne et la vidéo a
aussi déplu au ministre de la justice
eric dupond moretti a ordonné une
enquête à la grande surprise des
organisateurs de l'événement préparé
pendant deux mois sous le contrôle du
ministère de la justice le lan tatouages
non ça vous dirait même pas non rien du
tout un logo de slam sur un bras tout ça
même pas l'adresse du studio si j'avais
voulu retrouver par la semaine prochaine
le dif très bien ils sont fous
complètement le disent très bien
allons-y ce pas grave j'ai l'habitude tu
es sûr que tu peux pas réussir à
surmonter sa jeunesse luxe qui se passe
je manque de celui-là oui je m'évanouis
ici toi juste au niveau de la et donc
vous avez une sorte de corps de servir
comme ça la situation et dans ce cas-là
extrêmement tendue vous n'avez aucun
indice pour le moment ceci était notre
quatrième aventure il n'en reste qu'une
défi est relevé hier soir par alexis
landau qui a escaladé son corps ni
sécurité l'une des tours mercuriales de
bagnolet haute 222 m une pratique très
dangereuse et bien sûr interdite le
grimpeur parisien de 22 ans suit les
traces de alain robert l'homme araignée
qui a multiplié les ascensions
d'immeubles à mains nues partout dans le
monde à la robert qui avaient escaladé
cette même tour en 1995 a félicité son
successeur vaima la mare pour deux
indices pas à deux indices en cas de
victoire ou alors un autre candidat ou
une autre candidate pour un indice pas
moi ne soyez pas qu'on est non
évidemment ils jouent sur la peur celle
là où il ya la possibilité de gagner 2-1
disgrâce
alors ici on est 3
bonjour à l'essai 5 euros chacun
total en patron
brad pitt arrive sur ses tournages dans
sa maison roulante vaste salon familial
cuisine professionnelle et chambre à
coucher avec loge de maquillage
le camping-car de will smith est posé
sur 18 roues et tracté par un semi roman
le jour du tournage rototo devra se
dresser sur ses pattes arrières pour
observer lambert wilson
pour ça charlie entraîne son ragondins à
suivre le son d'un talkie walkie fixé à
une perche
totaux
et force est de constater que ce
ragondins jeu drôlement bien
celui de mariah carey la diva de la pop
surpasse tous les autres
en plus de ces extensions latérales un
deuxième étage se déploie et peut se
transformer en piste de danse
[Musique]
des véhicules qui valent chacun
plusieurs millions de dollars
certains prototypes sont encore plus
extravagants comme ce modèle amphibie
on ce bus avec piste d'hélicoptère sur
le toit haha
[Musique]
regardez assez extraordinaire les
toilettes ça devrait être une gamme à
l'époque
j'espère c'est en fait ça fait très de
touati que ça on compte sur toi tu es le
capitaine parfait je sais que tu vas y
arriver on a confiance allez on y va
pour le moment la seule chose qui a été
efficace depuis le début de cette
aventure c'est le générique début sans
voix dit elle va falloir comme celles
suscitées la route